I loved doing the rom-coms but I was
getting the scripts I felt like I could
do the same script tomorrow morning and
I was like that's fine but I want
something that's going to make me sweat
in my boots I want some work that's
going to challenge me make me go I'm
scared of this role for all the right
reasons and I can't wait to go attack it
that's what I was looking for and I
wasn't getting that in the rom-coms so I
stopped doing rom-coms I said no oh if
the first six months of not doing
rom-coms I wasn't doing anything only
thing that came in was rom-coms I said
no and for 14 more months nothing came
in I considered other careers didn't
know if it ever worked again but after
20 months of being gone unbranding as I
now call it being out of sight not being
in your theater or your living room in a
rom-com not seeing me shirtless on the
beach I became a new good idea for some
of those dramatic roles because where's
he been I don't know I haven't seen him
where has he been need motivation what's
the top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because when I started my first business
I really struggled to believe myself I
was making 300 bucks a month and quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the story series
of successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because I still need
the videos for myself today too so today
let's learn from one of the best Matthew
McConaughey and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
why do you pursue things that scare you
why seek the role that's hard because it
cost me something
because it cost
it comes with a price it's a bit of that
line don't pick a fight kids not really
a fight unless you can lose it it's not
really you know don't it's not really a
risk unless you lose the fight
I feel more alive in them I have an
experience in the making of them I'm
nervous every day I come to work
I feel like when I nail a day and I
knock and I know I did I feel like yes I
I have a measure at the end of the day
like you set out to do something you're
prepared for it you had intention and
you did it and maybe even became found
some magic in the day that
sleep good
knowing that I accomplished that day in
building the architecture of a
character's Arc through a story and then
if I could put the whole thing together
and it comes out the whole one old
performance turns out to be a beautiful
song an original song with that
character
then I'm like yes and I know that I was
highly responsible for that I was not
solely responsible but the most
responsible for that and that gives me
pleasure that gives me gratification
that makes me feel gives me significance
that gives me confidence
if I don't pull it off
and I do have a day where I'm like oh no
you didn't ever and it was my fault I
still I would rather with these kind of
rolls I can look in the mirror and go so
guess who's responsible not pulling it
off
you kind of hey in the same way when I
go guess who's responsible for pulling
up I like knowing who you and and and
and it was also again work that
challenged the Vitality of my life
dramatic roles allow the actor to have
as high of a ceiling or as low of a
basement from love to hate from
happiness to pain as that particular
actor wants to bring to it
that's what's inherently beautiful about
dramas okay you're the part you're
playing the role how does how how is are
you going to emulate that person through
yourself
um that is a vital thing that I feel
that makes me sweat that makes me sleep
better at the end of the day that gives
me a sense of accomplishment I'm like
yes I did what I intended to do I
prepared for it was ready oh the day
didn't go out I thought it was going to
go but I I called audibles along the way
enrolled and still told the truth on my
man the character that gratification
feels good rule number two is stop
sabotaging yourself how did you not
self-sabotage when you were just getting
hit after hit and opportunity after
opportunity and you were going downhill
um how did how do you not do that were
you self-sabotage and what do you
recommend for other people so they don't
do it when the opportunities are right
great great great topic because I have
tripped myself running downhill before I
have face planted you know broke my nose
and to to to proverbiably make sure I
was felt it's like you don't need to you
don't need to feel that hard you know
what I mean we don't need to draw blood
and kind of just to make sure we could
feel
um so there's been times I've not been
graceful when I was running downhill
um but
I shook hands with the fact that okay
obviously it means you give a damn
um obviously it means you you you're
trying to read through the mendacities
of life you're trying to get down to the
common denominator what really matters
to you
you're trying to uh uh uh understand all
this affluence and things coming to you
that you have never had yesterday that
now you have and you want 80 hours in a
day but they're still only given 24.
um I gotta get some discernment in here
and for me I've had to I've been
had the ability and I have taken what I
call fugamundi a walkabout I have taken
those solo trips with myself I've what
we talked about earlier in the
conversation come on to a place where I
could hear myself think where I could
get my head and my heart aligned in
those times of great affluence sometimes
it's all heady and I have a a a piece in
the book about
when you can ask yourself if you want to
before you do well in times of great
influence we have a lot of I can in
front of us months of opportunity and
too many options can make a tyrant out
of anybody yeah
um so it's a very heady thing and
sometimes that that's times when it's
like okay this all makes sense of habit
I don't really feel it inside my spirit
I don't know if it's really me if it's
really good for me if this is going to
turn me on and help me be and feed me
but geez I mean I've never had the
option before it sounds awesome I mean
yes well that's not a bad thing to do
but we got to check in on that because
you can look up and the tank can be on
on on on reserve yeah when you look in
the rear view Moon and go whoa I over
leverage myself with things that did not
feed me and pay me back and so how do we
need to take that time to go check in
and it can be a hairy hairy time man
because the answers don't come quickly
sometimes yeah and when they don't come
and you're shaking monkeys off your back
and you're not doing your own company
none of it makes sense and it's all
confusing and you're looking over there
and you want to go well you want to go
to entertainment or communication or you
want to pick up the phone or you want to
drink earlier either one of those things
that come up to to mask that you got to
hold try to hold back and say no I'm
going to sit in this discomfort this is
a prudent a Penance I am taking to get
to know myself
rule number three is start journaling
I've been keeping journals since I was
14 years old
um
and so I guess starting 15 years ago I
would always carry this Treasure Chest
full of the journals I've been keeping
and they were filling up that treasure
chest and I would take it with me to any
place that we went for an extended
amount of time put it over there to the
right of my proverbial desk and go have
it there because if you get the itch and
you get some time I dare you to go on
that treasure chest and see what's in
there well I've threatened to open up
that treasure chest and see what those
journals held for the past 15 years
didn't have the courage really to uh to
open it up didn't didn't want to make
the time to go in there because I was
intimidated of looking back at 50 years
or however many years of my life I'm not
one for really liking to look back over
my shoulder I'm somebody who likes to
you know I'm still someone who rather
enjoys making the sandwich more than
eating it I like making my movies more
than even like watching them I like
doing things moving on and uh and
heading forward so well you must have
had some idea too when you were making
those journals at least in principle
that you owed an obligator to yourself
at some point to look back over them and
I can see that that would be
intimidating because you're creating a a
task for yourself a task of
reconsideration and contemplation I
suppose
well my my excuse was
oh when I die Camillo open them up and
if there's something worth sharing
she'll do it
um in martyrdom you know if there's
something worth it rule number four is
be inquisitive when you went back and
looked at your journals were you
surprised at the wisdom of some of the
things that you said when you were
younger was there anything that stuck
out that you didn't expect
um
obviously the earlier
diary entries were
wise why what where when house it was
the questions there was a question mark
after everything so I was always seeking
the question as I evolved and got older
I started to answer some of those
questions and could sum them up in a in
a wisdom bomb or an aphorism or a bumper
sticker right
but
it didn't lead to any fewer questions my
questions evolved I think but uh as I
said earlier what I was looking at what
I was at the questions I was asking at
14 about existence and who am I and
what's what matters and what's life
about
um how the world Works who am I in this
world I still question those but to
interrupt you quickly there it is
unusual for a 14 year old to be asking
those kinds of questions
so I'm curious like where do you think
that comes from in you I don't know you
know I don't know how to answer that
because
we weren't raised as a very
introspective family we always have our
prayer and gratitude as a family we were
raised as consistent extrovert I mean
like it wasn't
allowed to watch TV or read because my
mom would say
why read about or watch somebody do
something that you can go do yourself
get outside as always go go do it Go
experience it so you know I don't know
where my my family my mom wasn't really
a writer my dad wasn't
um I mean I was always though early on
The Inquisitor of the family the
interrogator the one who wasn't
satisfied with Mom and Dad just going
because we said so I'll go well let's
get underneath this that's why I was
going to be a lawyer I was they were
like dude you Matthew the youngest one
you debate things and question things to
the nth degree and it's exhausting at
times so I was always sort of wanting to
get to the underbelly of the meaning of
things
um at a very early age so I don't know
where that came from but that's just
kind of I think always been who I am
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is enjoy your own
company you knew that there is something
to be extracted from living life so you
know whether you would agree with the
statement that there's power and
loneliness
um certainly you are creating situations
from which you had the frame of
reference I can extract value from this
how did you get that frame of reference
like that's so useful but I don't think
most people have that
you know I don't know exactly where
where I got it I mean I would say again
to call back that Australian year where
I did not have a choice where I was
forced into that situation and saw the
green light assets from being alone and
quite lonely
um I do think uh that there's Great
Value in being alone and if we are alone
and we get bored
and we don't like the company ding May
that light go off to say that does not
mean
we need to pick up our phone to get some
attention or go to the bottle to to to
to to to to ease the anxiety or go
online to get some feedback to entertain
yourself no it's actually a great time
to say no sit here in that discomfort
long enough to go okay until you come
out the other side to go all right I'm
good with me again
now it's part of that I write about it
about traveling in general
ideally you don't go to a place you know
I always say this don't
I don't want to leave a place I travel
to until I get to the point of going ah
I could live here this could be my
existence as soon as I get to that point
then I'm like okay you go
now I can go that's the same thing in
the personal Journeys stick with it till
you get through the discomfortable to
uncomfortable times until you go you
know what I can spend time with myself I
could do this wish I could do this
forever well then it's okay to go to
re-engage pick up your phone go see your
friends go have a drink what have you go
look for those things that are other
relationships in life but hopefully not
until there's Great Value in not doing
that until you go I'm good with me and
me for right now rule number six is stay
in the zone I know in my heart that as
we've been saying you don't there's no
destination it's all a verb Life's a
verb it's a process you don't ever
achieve
so I'm trying to reframe that into going
will keep achieving in the pursuit of
the unachievable I mean and make steps
so I do want to evolve but a lot of
times I'll emotionally feel
insignificant if I don't achieve
something interesting and I think it's a
uh uh sometimes it's good because it is
good to accomplish it is good to set a
goal get what we want go after it other
times it's like
you kind of just need to sit still or
just stay and stay in your perpetual
motion and go forward and quit you don't
miss the process for the for for the the
clinching seek of the result don't let
the result tell you ah now I'm
significant
you know what I mean
um at the same time I've had a lot
better results when I was stuck to the
process oh
when I wasn't as worried about the
result when I the best golfers shoot the
best rounds when they walk off 18
thinking they're going to the next tee
boxes someone's got to tell them no you
finished the round you shot 63. oh I did
no I've done my best work when we rap
and I'm like okay see y'all tomorrow
morning and they're like no that's it we
rap the show is over you're like oh
really oh wow stay in the zone in the
process and I found that more results
will come your way rule number seven is
look out for green lights talk to us
about what is a green light but more
deeply for me what I'm fascinated by is
how do you know when something's a green
light and sometimes do we miss them like
do we miss green lights as well
absolutely we miss them all the time
um sometimes they're right in front of
us we don't see them daily because we're
not in a place to receive them to
recognize them to be aware of them to
see a certain situation with that
sometimes we see red and yellow lights
where they're actually
brain life sometimes we slow down and
stop or feel like we're getting stopped
when it's actually no it was it was free
there was no glass on the on the on the
floor you could pass through that dark
hallway it was it was it was a free ride
whatever that may be a lot of times I
think I know that we can create green
lights engineer them for our future by
the choices we make daily
um I call it since it's a version of
delayed gratification uh it's a version
of rli return on our investments it's
like teeing ourself up being kind to our
future self teeing up more green lights
in our future
um they're based on a mix of
responsibility and Freedom the choices
we make compounding assets of our future
um if we for instance because sad to say
I'm gonna lie cheat still get it get a
short money green light right now for me
well you're actually teeing up yellow
and red lights in the future because
everywhere you go you gotta look over
your shoulder and go oh is someone here
that a lot cheap stole from and the cops
drafting whatever that may be as a
metaphor if we take care of our business
today it can be simple simple thing
here's a simple green thing put your
coffee in a coffee field to the night
before you go to bed you're still happy
the next morning just to press that
button because sometimes it's hard to
make a coffee when you hadn't had your
coffee so there's there can be simple
little green lights where you tee
yourself up for for uh be more success
and ease in the future and then like I
said sometimes you can engineer them
sometimes they will just fall on our lap
um and how do we how do how do we find
them I've found that we find them by
either enduring through something
or pivoting and having on having another
look at something a different way or
raising the white flag and saying I give
I'm going to live to fight another day
because I'm going to fight another
battle here well number eight is hold
yourself accountable I'm gonna test out
my threshold of Hedonism I'm going to I
don't want to be harmful I don't want to
be mean I don't I don't want to be a
mean to anyone else or myself at the
same time I'm going to give myself a a
Saturday night POV for for some time and
I did it for a couple of years
um and then I just noticed that okay
this feels revolutionary not
evolutionary this feels like a stop not
a stay this Indulgence an option to
indulge is not I'm not really feeling an
Ascension in my life I'm cool with where
it is I'm not griping about it I'm
enjoying it and I'd be silly if I didn't
but I'm not really feeling a build an
Ascension in my life and I want to feel
build
um so
I decided to get out of there and go
away so I knew at that time it was it
that that was a stop and not a stay I
also
you know during that time at the end of
that time really started to question my
belief in in God and stuff and so I
remember saying
you know okay you're a Believer but why
and is your belief is your sense of
belief Matthew
your fatalistic sense of belief that
it's all faith is it is that it you
using that as an excuse almost in ways
in your life to let yourself off the
hook and I remember going well let's
just
put two hands on the wheel of
self-determination here and let's be our
own judge and jury Matthew and let's
call it out and not rely on hey no you
know what if you know it's all been
written and so I went through a very I
would call it an agnostic time and as I
said in the book it wasn't as much of a
time where I disbelieved God it was a
time where I said you need to hold
yourself more accountable Matthew you
need to have both hands on your wheel of
where you're going because you're
letting yourself slide on just about on
a lot of stuff and I want to go test
that out I want to hold you I want to
hold you more accountable Matthew so I
want to hold myself more accountable and
um went through a couple of years of
that it was a very good exercise and my
relationship with God I believe my
belief is that God was smiling and going
yeah good on good on you way to grab a
hold of the wheel because I didn't
because yeah you do have free will and
and I don't I and it didn't make me
think that anything's going to change
after this life but it did make me say
hey while I'm in it remember that I've
got freedom of choice and hold my more
responsible for my choices rule number
nine is trust yourself what would your
hero at 60 say about who you are today
looking back
yeah it's a great question and one I
think we should all ask ourselves have I
had that great sit down with our future
self
um I think you'd say make sure make sure
you trust yourself
make sure you did a good job of trusting
yourself but you know what you could
have even trusted yourself more
there's always we could even trust
yourself more
he made some things maybe maybe you made
some things a little too hard maybe
where you didn't need the resistance
just sit back and trust yourself so I
made some things hard because you felt
like you needed to feel it you you
already done the work you would already
you already laid the laid the rails on
the road just now right up now stay
vital keep those rails greased keep
yourself in shape mentally spiritually
but overall you you've done it you did
it you do you're doing good at trusting
yourself and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
be confident there's this zen-like
confidence about you that I will say
even to this day feeling like I now know
you I still don't think I understand
where it comes from
huh
okay
um
look confidence is
so important I'm not always
as confident as I may appear
um
I get frustrated I struggle I I go
through my own bouts of sense of lack of
significance I get I'm addicted
sometimes to accomplishment to get my
confidence
um and
in those times I think when I am not as
confident is usually when I'm a little
bit more spiritually barren
meaning I'm when I get consumed with
Mortal rewards mortal failures hurt me
more Mortal successes
rise me up more into a false confidence
which they really are
um when a more spiritually sound I
I'm seeing the infinite game
I'm thinking about
this life is
one little run for me in the blip of
history and I'll be gone what am I
leaving behind so when I started
thinking about the infinite game the
bigger picture The Immortal rewards
um being if you're a believer of a habit
or something else or the immortal
rewards of after we're gone what do we
leave for the Next Generation or my
children
I get extremely confident and clear and
my ego is married to service and and
thoughtfulness and the selfish idea for
me happens to be what would be the most
selfless idea and vice versa I'm not
objectifying people or the world or
judging them as harshly and as as
arrogantly as I can do sometimes when
I'm less confident
um I think that's that uh if that
explains it that's that's where that
comes from when I'm when I'm on my
frequency
the actual making of a film the
day-to-day going to work the
construction of them has always been my
favorite thing I like making a film much
more than like watching them I do and
even the ones I'm in I I really love the
coming together with a whole bunch of
people having an idea on paper and
everyone's got Everyone's an expert at
what they do and you're and you're off
on this journey you've got ideas but
then you just let them you let it let it
go and see what it can become I love the
making that's when I'm happiest is when
I'm making
a film or telling their story the day to
day
and more so than watching them really
um
the I mean look I kind of Define that
for myself about four years ago process
stay in process head down in process
stay in your bubble
and when it's over be that fulfillment
notice when I started noticing that
fulfillment of it I just finished well
that's enough
that's it I don't know if this thing I
don't know if it's even coming out
I don't even know if I don't know what's
going to turn in man I hope I hope we
got it and I hope the director put
something good together but I don't know
nothing I can do about that all I know
is this experience that I say go have
the experience McConaughey and if I can
love this experience and at the end of
it I'm like may never even hear that
film again I never even know that story
again it may be gone let me find out
that all the negatives got fried the
X-ray machine there is no film but I've
got to be that's okay I had an
experience
when I got selfish for that
for that
ex experience when I got that process
enjoying that process the day-to-day
architecture of making a movie and
creating a role that's
that's when I'm in the happiest and
more results have come that way in an
odd way
you know
um
but I just saw when I started really
approaching them as this is a finite
thing and this is just that experience
other than that
I'm not producing this thing I'm not the
one editing I don't know what it's going
to be
that's it and then all of a sudden they
come out and you go oh I think we got a
good one
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my recent one-on-one with
Matthew McConaughey check out my
interview right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there sometimes it's not
about what decision you make just make
one and commit to it self-determination
and faith intentionality and trust I
mean it's always a balance of those two